welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series and get the free bonus
companion worksheets that go with this
video check the link in the description
below alright today is day 11 and we're
gonna learn how you can overcome your
fear you are unusually fearless and
willing to go in the face of other
people telling you something that's
crazy
and I know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out where does that come
from or how do you think about making a
decision when everyone tells you this is
a crazy idea
where do you get the internal strength
to do that well office well I'd say I
actually think I feel feel fair quite
strongly so it's not as though I just
have the absence of fear I've I feel it
quite strongly but there are times when
if something is important enough you
believe in it enough that you do you do
it in spite of the fear so speaking of
important things like people shouldn't
think III I should if you should think
well I feel fear about this and
therefore I shouldn't do it it's normal
to be to feel fair like you'd have to
definitely something mentally wrong you
shouldn't feel fair so you just feel it
and let the importance of it drive you
to do it anyway yeah you know actually
we're something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree you could just if
just accept the probabilities then that
diminishes fear so my starting SpaceX I
thought the odds of success were less
than 10% and I just accepted that
actually probably I would just lose lose
everything but that maybe would make
some progress if we could just move the
ball forward even if we died maybe some
other company could pick up the baton
and move and keep moving it forward so
that were still do some good yeah same
with Tesla I thought your odds of a car
company succeeding were extremely low
skydiving is a really interesting
confront with fear
[Applause]
you go out the night before and you know
you take a drink with your friends and
somebody says yeah we should go
skydiving tomorrow and you go yeah we'll
go skydiving yeah and you go home by you
by yourself you like me right you're
like well yeah I mean they was drunk too
so then that night you're laying in your
bed and you just keep you yeah and
you're terrified you keep imagining over
and over again jumping out of an
airplane and you can't figure out why
you would do that so you get there and
then you have this safety brief and
you're standing there and the guys to
tell you what the chute doesn't open
what's gonna happen is you're doing you
a lot of help with woken up so you get
onto the airplane and you're sitting
there and and you know it's extra
because you sitting on some dudes lap
some stranger trying to make small talk
yeah man so you go you'd be you be
jumping with people all the time so you
fly and you go up to 14,000 feet and
somebody opens the door and in that
moment you realize you've never been in
a freaking airplane with the door open
terror terror terror talent and then
people start going out of the airplane
and the guy walks you up to the end of
the thing and you're standing and your
toes are on the edge and you're looking
out down to death they say on three two
and he pushes you on - because people
grab one three and you fall out of the
airplane
and in one second you realize that it's
the most blissful experience of your
life you're flying
there's zero fear you realize that the
point of maximum danger is the point of
minimum fear the lesson for me was why
were you scared in your bed the night
before what do you need that fear for
everything up to the stepping out
there's actually no reason to be scared
and then in that moment all of a sudden
where you should be terrified is the
most blissful experience of your life
and God placed the best things in life
on the other side of fear somebody once
said that the chains of heaven are too
light to be felt until they're too heavy
to be broken I have been terrified of
public speaking I couldn't do it I throw
up
and I know if I didn't cure it then
they'd never cure and so I so I'd add in
the paper to the Dale Carnegie horse
which worked on developing your ability
to speak in public and I went down there
be a good smile as the thing the thing
at the puppies feel what a puppy wig
they made it to all these crazy things
to get out of ourselves and so we stood
on tables and did all kinds of things
I hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different so in my
office you will not see the degree I got
from the University of Nebraska you'll
not see the master's degree I got from
Columbia University but you'll see the
little wart certificate I got from the
Dale Carnegie of course feel the fear
and do it anyway that famous quote I
want to tell you a little bit about the
science so there's this famous
neuroscience is called Antonio Damasio
and he did a really interesting study
where he discovered that our body senses
fear before our mind even realizes it
and when fear or danger speaking to your
boss calling a prospect going to the gym
when you're not proud of the way that
you look and you know it's not fear like
terror it's more that low-grade
agitation in your body
I felt it yesterday because I went to a
bootcamp class yesterday and I'm not in
good shape and I don't do bootcamp
classes and Kendall and I are staying at
this hotel where holy cow everybody
seems like there's some sort of
professional weightlifter or Instagram
model and so it was really intimidating
and I could feel that agitation in my
body that's the kind of fear I'm talking
about I'm not talking about the
paralysis fear your life is threatened
and you really are in a life-or-death
situation I'm talking about the
low-grade agitation that is there when
you're about to do something that makes
you feel a little uncomfortable
so when fear or danger is sensed in the
body your body begins a stress response
before your mind even catches up and if
you want to take control of your life
you've got to take control of that
physical state and it starts with
catching these moments everyone when you
start to feel it where every milestone
while you might be excited about the
milestone there's a part of the
milestone that you don't want to face
are you hearing me and listen to me I'm
knocked out the courseware boom got it
done in order ET why did it take you two
years ET after you finished your
coursework why did it take you two
get started with the dissertation I'm
gonna be 100 with you there one look not
all the course work out but when I
finally got to the dissertation I had to
get to that demon I had to deal with it
I had to face it face what we're not
talking about elementary school middle
school high school I've had a professor
or two tell me in college that you will
never get your dissertation that that
that while your writing has improved but
in terms of your analysis like you are
not critical enough to do a dissertation
or are you hear what I'm telling you
we're talking about look math I love
math coming up why it is what it is so
please excuse my dear Aunt Sally like it
is what it is right it's not subjective
writing is subjective I've had teachers
to look at my work and and ship it in
the park and the fear to fear what the
fear of rejection rightness is if my
teachers were so subjective I put my
whole heart into it I put everything I
can put and they tell me edit it again a
revision after revision and it after are
you hear what I'm telling you I had to
deal with the fact that writing has
never really been my strong suit
and even though I've worked hard and I
put in hours and hours in the back of my
mind I in the back of my mind I could
hear the teacher say Ichi you'll have
what it takes to get a dissertation I'm
a grown man dealing with that fear I'm a
grown man I'm dealing with the rejection
of getting all that read all that read
on my paper of having to do it over and
over and over and over and come on come
on somebody fills me you feel like
you'll do a hundred and twenty percent
you'll give everything you have and it
still won't be enough I feel you I was
there a part of the milestone is what
does I give everything and it ain't
enough what if I put my whole heart my
whole mind my whole soul into it et and
it's not enough what if I do it in our
fam and so I feel you so you're just
like you're not gonna do it all because
you rather not do it and find out the
truth and I'm telling you got to do me a
favor we gotta face your fear and you
gotta do it anyway
we had to face his fear that's right yup
I know you see Ichi be slow and you
right I am be smoke but it don't mean be
smart without fear
it don't mean be smart without lure
anxiety and don't mean be smoke and I'm
just 120 percent sure no I have to live
my faith - and I made up in my mind
Ichi you got to go after eat look I
finished my coursework it took me two
years why cuz it took me two years to
get over the fear it took me two years
to get over the anxiety it took me two
years to finally say Goliath here I come
Goliath you might be taller than me you
might be bigger than me you might be
stronger than me but I'm coming and I'd
rather die trying
I'd rather die going after this
dissertation I'd rather give everything
our guy really give a year I'd rather
put in work and fail you cannot try it
off when I was younger life in society
made this big world with all these
endless possibilities in this
possibilities my wife made my
possibilities this big yeah because it
made me afraid of all these different
things yeah so all this stuff trapped my
mind is shackled my brain it made me a
prisoner within my own self saying this
is all I can do because why I'm afraid
of this I'm insecure over here I got
stuff down over here back behind me good
one who knows who's behind me I'm like
look behind me so your life is this big
versus it being like I can do all this
out here if I start to break down this
ball you know these these these
different walls and barriers and that's
what I started realizing I couldn't
become a Navy SEAL I could become this
but I was afraid of the water think
about this I know why the you're gonna
go be a Navy SEAL when all you do is
play in the water
yeah four and we all play we're in it
and we're living in it your time
knowledge in swimming for example the
ocean is unforgiving yeah so my mind is
I'm gonna go be a Navy SEAL yeah if I
didn't face that fear no one would ever
know me I was number three behind
Michelle Obama for a long time it's my
book sold out yeah and I was a guy just
21 years ago yeah who was 300
can barely read and write and now the
book just two spots behind Michelle
Obama yeah hopefully we get it above
today right just because I was afraid
yeah but you overcome those fears guess
what happens the whole world you unlock
this door and everything opens back up
again you know I actually took this
question from Twitter and I answered the
question in one word you've lived a life
dominated by doubt and fear how do you
step into bravery step that's how you
step into bravery step take the step
step aggressively towards your fear and
that that step towards your fear is the
step into bravery because we're per
scared of what we don't know and there
is only one way to learn and to know and
that is to confront that fear you have
to step you have to go and this simple
action
this simple attitude it answers so many
questions
my theory here would be if you're afraid
of fighting and altercations go change
it so if you're afraid of heights work
on some rock climbing climbing if you're
afraid of the water it's time to swim
it's time to surf it's trying to get out
there if you're afraid of pull-ups if if
you're afraid of pulps do pull-ups if
you're in squats do squats if you're
afraid of public speaking go speak in
public mm-hmm if you're afraid to start
a business start a business make it
small and on all these what you have to
do is you have to mitigate the risk and
you have to ease yourself into it
but you got to go for it and eventually
you will overcome that fear but the hard
part is you got to take that first step
you got to take that first step to begin
to inoculate yourself against the fear
against the fear of the thing that's in
your mind because that fear generally is
in your mind yeah you know when you get
up on stage do you a public speaking
people are not gonna throw tomatoes at
you and say oh my
you're an idiot to get off the stage no
they're gonna sit there you know so
there's nothing to fear yeah it's in
it's in your head but you get on the web
and you did check out who's Dame Dash
and there's so much crap how do you deal
with that and how do you suggest other
people deal with it when they reach a
certain level of celebrity I mean when
you sign on to being a certain level of
celebrity you got to know they're gonna
say things and you know things are going
to get eyeballs and get people to buy in
and you know I just I really don't care
and one of the reasons why I think I've
been successful is because I didn't care
if I cared I probably would be too
scared to promote people that people
don't want to promote you know it takes
fearlessness to be first you know to not
move with a crowd to move alone you know
and you get scrutinized by people that
do move with a crowd because they got to
make you look bad to make themselves
look good it's all part of the game it's
like a guy that's in high school that
gets all the girls the rest of the dudes
hate him in high school so my whole life
has been being that guy in high school
that everyone hates because I keep
taking their girls good understand that
it's not a bad life so that's how I look
at it but the price of success is
unsuccessful people don't like you
who cares for are successful people
don't care about what another person is
doing because accessible people want
everybody else does diseases exactly
that's my no that's this whole mindset
that people don't understand right so
it's usually a bunch of unsuccessful
bitter bitter people and you know I was
a guy in school that you know was got
kicked out of every school I was the
class clown you know I wasn't the guy
that you would traditionally think would
be go this far so me making it made all
my teachers look stupid every principal
that kicked me out of school look stupid
you know I went to South Kent in
Connecticut on scholarship I didn't come
back the next year the next
I came back was on a helicopter and I
landed it on the soccer field you know
that when I got kicked out of Dwight in
the seventh grade you know my son came
back and they were asking me you know I
put my son to D I paid full tuition plus
extras for tutoring and they asked me to
build a library I'm like the same
principal that kicked me out is asking
me to build a library so it's egg on all
their faces you know my success makes a
lot of people look like they were wrong
because a lot of people articulated the
fact that I wouldn't be what I am today
and either way either way I didn't care
but I think it's kind of funny it's egg
all over they face scramble overcoming
fear is one of the greatest moves a
person can make first of all we have to
ask yourself what causes fear fears
caused by ignorance not knowing and if
we're gonna go and do anything new if
we're gonna break out of a paradigm if
we're gonna change habit patterns we're
wandering into an area we've never been
and you know fear stops most people
you'll find people afraid to talk to a
stranger you'll find individuals afraid
to stand up and ask the question in
front of other people you'll find
salespeople afraid to make a sales call
afraid to ask for the order stop and
think of how confining that is a person
is putting themself into a small cell
but it's in their own mind the doors
aren't locked they can open and you can
walk away to freedom if you learn to
overcome fear when you face fear it
leaves you face the thing you fear and
it'll leave you that's really the secret
of it in fact if you hold yourself back
because of fear your life actually comes
to a stop because nothing gets better
than it is you've got to be courageous
now Crete just people aren't without
fear courageous people are the ones that
face their fear I think Eddie
Rickenbacker pointed that out the great
pilot don't let fear stop you make up
your mind you're going to step out and
do it stop and think of the number of
people that are in jobs that they don't
like and they're afraid to leave
or people in relationships that are
destructive and they're afraid to leave
this is a terrible way to live and it's
not necessary
it's just caused by ignorance and when
we step out and do something we gain an
awareness we develop an understanding
and like that the fear is gone make up
your mind that fear is not going to stop
you from doing the thing you really want
to do step out and do it today it seems
like you can't open a book or read a
blog post these days without hearing
somebody tell you to follow your passion
or follow your bliss or follow your
heart and yes I have said those things
too but today I want to talk about the
power of going in what can often feel
like the opposite direction I want to
talk about the power of following your
fear I'm not talking about following
you're very useful fear of big moving
vehicles and walking in front of a bus
nor am I talking about doing anything
stupid or irresponsible that could ruin
you financially what I am talking about
though is the power of following good
fear directive fear the kind of fear
that you feel when you have an idea that
just won't leave you alone an idea about
doing something that you've always
wanted to do something that's different
and bold and kind of risky where part of
you saying oh no I actually couldn't do
that but the deeper wiser part of you
wants this thing so damn bad and the
moment you imagine yourself going for it
you have worries like you know will
people laugh at me will they ignore me
maybe this isn't even really an idea
what if I do it and it sucks
am I gonna destroy my reputation am I
gonna lose my marriage and my family and
wind up living on the streets my friend
Steven Pressfield talks about this kind
of fear in the war of art and he says
remember our rule of thumb the more
scared we are of a work or calling the
more sure we can be that we have to do
it and he continues the more fear we
feel about a specific enterprise the
more certain we can be that that
enterprise is important to us and the
growth of our soul
can't hit a home run unless you're in
the batter's box and you swing away
right everybody understand that most of
you have never been in the batter's box
or on the crease so in that regard you
really and I'm not giving you an excuse
for not being more successful but in
that regard I can cut you a little bit
of slack because you've never put
yourself in a position to succeed but
it's been out of fear everybody in this
room has had an opportunity to succeed
at something but fear has kept you back
false expectations appearing real tell
people your your concept of the paddle
well there's a paddle for everybody's
ass we all know that and every day you
just get up and I don't fear anything
but I'll worry about everything and the
day you stop worrying in good times the
paddle will get your behind and and and
so his greatest things are in life I
know you're only a few steps or a few
incidents away from something bad happen
and you can never forget it did you have
fear as a kid and you just got into
enough business scuffles that you
figured your way through things or have
you always been fearless I'm pretty
fearless but I do worry about everything
but you know once again you know the
book and this is why Harper's asked me
to write the book because of all my
Tillman isms you got to know what you
know when what you don't know and and I
knew that I understood business now
don't ask me to you know go win an Emmy
I took guitar lessons for four years and
I still struggle playing the guitar I
can't draw a stick person very good but
I knew that I understood business so I
know what I know and I know how to do
due diligence on a deal I don't worry
about making a bad deal because I feel
like that's what I know
so no fear when it comes to that so many
people look at fear or even doubt but
they look at fear as if it's the
emotional enemy you know it's the enemy
emotion like oh I can deal with
compassion I can do it love I can do it
understanding but when fear comes oh my
god bad thing No
first of all change your release
to fear I've said this before fear is
not the enemy the feeling of fear is
just like any other emotion fear is
actually informing you fear is telling
you that you need to do something either
do more research get some support get
some insight study a little more slow
down fear is actually feeding you so
then ask yourself the question what do I
need to do think or go get to dissipate
this fear because remember fear is fear
becomes present when you've made up
something that could happen in the
future and it makes you afraid right now
like oh my god I'm afraid I can get hurt
in this relationship oh my god I'm
afraid lose my money well you're just
projecting a story that you made up then
back into that fear go okay wait then
what do I need to do to minimize the
fear that I might get hurt what do I
need to do to minimize the fear that I
might lose my money what do I need to do
of course you can't a 100% eliminate the
possibility but you can greatly reduce
the chances by asking what am i afraid
of what am i afraid that's gonna happen
and then secondly recognize that fear
doesn't mean stop people think oh I'm
afraid let me stop okay that's a choice
to stop fear doesn't necessarily mean
stop fear might mean proceed with
caution or proceed with more strategy
fear does it whenever I'm feeling fear
it doesn't tell me so I don't you think
now to stop with a fear I do think to
slow down go get some help go get some
inside voice my fear so that it's not
just all in my head
recognize that fear is going to come in
when you're playing bigger than you've
ever played before I say if your knees
aren't knocking and your teeth are
chattering just a little at least then
you're not playing big enough the bigger
you play the more you're gonna feel your
knees knock and you don't hear your
teeth chatter and I'm always playing big
I'm always feeling my knees knock and
I'm always here in my teeth chatter
but I've created a relationship with
that fear to go hold on let's say fears
right here fear what are you telling me
because fear really is its it's a story
it's it's something you think could
happen and could it happen yeah but
could it not happen yeah so don't try to
outrun fear
don't try to outrun doubt and definitely
don't wait until and fear are gone
before you move
find out what doubt and fear needs to
dissipate into the nothingness that it
always was what does it need and then
understand that action brings clarity so
the more you move forward the more
action you're in the more clarity you
get because action breeds clarity and
clarity comes with action so many times
just sitting on the sidelines waiting
waiting to get completely clear before
you take any action and clarity is
waiting for you to get an action to
create clarity so be willing be willing
it's a play full out a little nervous
dr. Alfred Golson who since passed was a
very unusual guy and he told me that mr.
Brown you have cancer I said can you
give me a second opinion he's yes and
you're ugly too because you know those
three words you have cancer three of the
most feared words in seven different
languages I saw it as a fight and and
and from that time to this time you know
my PSA was 2400 and that's central
prostate specific antigen and now it's
below zero
metastasized in seven areas of my body
which was a good thing because seven is
my lucky number okay it slowed it then
no I
I never was fearful that I was going to
die from it and and I think that I read
something by dr. Norman Cousins he wrote
a book called the biology of hope and he
talked about the fact that when
something happens to you you don't deny
it you defy it and I was defiant that
I'm going to beat this I'm going to
handle this that they're people who many
times when something happens to them
that they embrace it from a place of
fear and it takes them out and Elsie
Robinson said thanks my helper to you
and things were happen around you but
the most important things the things
that happen in you and you have to stand
up inside yourself and deal with it and
handle it when Cheryl says what is
Gaby's biggest fear good question you
know I think that I think that I don't
even want to say them out loud yeah how
about that
cool I see you finally yeah because I
don't want to bring energy to it yeah
sure I'll expand on that bit we all have
fears you never know how committed to
love we are no matter how deeply deeply
connected we are to our own our own
spiritual practice and to God into the
universe we will always have fear you
know unless we somehow become
enlightened which is possible but we
will live with fear and it's it's it's
not that the fear goes away completely
as the spiritual student it's just that
you don't believe in it anymore so when
you ask me to share my fears
it's like talking about something that
it's like not true for me so of course
there's fear and they pop up and they're
you know it's present but it's not real
for me so it feels like like I'm doing
the world a disservice to say that love
fear of the future much of my anxiety is
about what will happen to me going
forward fear that I will lose what I
already have although I won't get what I
want
we cannot be governed by fear but we
should respect fear it's a type of
awareness a type of wisdom there is
knowledge in fear I suppose if we feel a
lot of
and anxiety my daughter's just walked in
we should acknowledge that we are living
in projections
we're not present in the moment Mooji
the great meditation teacher from whom I
get some of my sparkliest blankets said
we are more than just a vessel for
concepts when you are feeling something
when you are projecting something try to
identify more with the observer of the
phenomena rather than the phenomena
itself say for example I'm frightened
because I'm flying to America for free
mumps to be in the TV show ballers what
is the nature of the fear really I feel
like I can get something from being in
ballers like maybe things will go well
and I'll be in ballers again well that
happened last time and it did not
resolve my spiritual problems fear is
itcool as our all physical sensations to
move closer to God except for things
like you know bodily symptoms that might
be a call to move closer to some vitamin
C or a physician so there is wisdom in
fear but in many of us myself I would
have to include in this that instinct
that impulse that sensation of anxiety
has gone awry I've witnessed it this way
there are probably multiple neurological
networks and sometimes my bias becomes
comes towards the fearful one like I
live in this circuit of fear
all information causing more fear
sometimes it takes an external influence
like a powerful mentor to say stop being
frightened to sort of jerk me on to the
positive perspective objective reality
they say may never have changed eternal
and infinite every moment continually
being lived out always everywhere
forever that means there is no change
there is no past there is no future
particularly not if you can well to your
consciousness to be observer instead of
identifying with external phenomena
don't fear the future because the future
doesn't exist
we've got some difficult days ahead but
it Rizza don't matter with me now
because I've been to the mountaintop
like anybody I would like to live a long
life longevity has its place but I'm not
concerned about that now I just want to
do God's will the promised land to the
promised man
I'm not a man
now I've got a special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best like 30 questions
of the day it's not enough to just watch
this video you have to do something so
pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets you can get them for free
check the link in the description below
alright here we go question number one
what do you want to do but you're afraid
of number two how will you change your
relationship with that fear and number
three what's the first step you can take
today towards it and if you are doing
the best life thirty challenge with me
give me a hashtag best live 30 in the
comments below so I can celebrate with
you
people aren't afraid of feeling you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street corner you'll
record a video but you'll never release
it you'll be your own biggest critic but
you won't at the same time also be your
own biggest fan that needs to change
starting today
so my biggest fear is disappointing
people I'm terrified of disappointing
people the idea that you would come to
my thought Leadership Academy and I
would teach you how to win on social
media and get the ideas out of your head
and pay $2,000 would do it the idea that
that you would come and be disappointed
destroys me and it's led to some
positive things in that I always over
deliver I'm always obsessed I'm always
putting so much value to that even if
you only get 10% of the value I'm giving
you still more than made the money that
you invested into any of the stuff that
I'm doing but at the same time it's
still this fear and so I want to attack
the fear I teach myself to attack the
fear and I think you should too even
just attacking it for the sake of
attacking it is good even if it doesn't
lead to a positive result for your
business it's good because you're
building strength because you're pushing
your comfort zone because you're getting
better because you're growing that's
worth something that's a ton of value
because if you can conquer your fear of
doing this one thing that translates to
every of your life if you teach yourself
to have more courage that translates
everywhere so maybe you're afraid of if
you're on a cruise ship and they bring
up couples and they do a game show
you're afraid of what might happen
that game do it how does that make you a
better entrepreneur makes you thousand
times better as an entrepreneur because
that's the same view that you face in
your business that fear going on that
game show on the cruise ship that fear
of taking your phone and recording the
video in public on the street these
fears that seem like nothing they show
up everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business and so
learning to tackle them especially in
low stakes starts building the muscle if
you want to join the best like 30
challenge for free click the link right
here below me or if you want more videos
to overcome fear check out the playlist
right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there